An important question about this
model is, what are the goals?
That is with respect to these complexity
measures, what makes an algorithm good?
What you want is actually pretty simple.
The first goal is work optimality.
That is, your two level algorithm should
do the same asymptotic work as the best
ran algorithm.
Here W-star is intended to mark
the work of the best RAM algorithm.
That is, the one that doesn't
have a memory hierarchy.
The statement is no different from what
you would say about parallel algorithms.
Namely, don't blow up
the asymptotic work.
Ka-boom!
There's a second goal.
You want an algorithm that achieves
high computational intensity.
Here's a more formal statement.
Computational intensity or just
intensity is just the ratio of work to
words transferred,
denoted by a capital I.
Intensity has units of
operations per word.
Operations per word, put another way,
computational intensity measures
the data reuse of your algorithm.
If this ratio is large, it means
you're doing more operations for
every word that you
transfer to fast memory.
That's a good thing, but, you don't want
an algorithm that maximizes this ratio
at the expense of sub optimal work.
In other words goals 1 and
2 go hand in hand, and
I hope this fact reminds you of work and
span.